bueno la situación en haití continúa
siendo bastante complicada
como has dicho muy bien las personas
siguen sanando afectadas siguen buscando
esperando ayuda humanitaria sin embargo
continuamos trabajando sin parar hemos
logrado alcanzar hasta el momento unas
25.000 personas ya con una asistencia
para hogares lonas kits de higiene kit
de cocina que les ayuda por lo menos a
tratar de mantener una dignidad humana
mientras logran recuperarse del todo las
familias están tanto en las zonas
urbanas como las zonas rurales tienen
problemas para el acceso al agua también
estamos trabajando en este sentido
tratar de proveer agua a familias en
distintas partes y como también ha
pasado han tenido daños de
infraestructura de todo tipo tanto de
las escuelas como de las clínicas
necesitamos también trabajar mucho la
parte de salud porque hay un riesgo
también de enfermedades transmitidas por
agua ya por ende ese tipo de problemas
entonces la situación continúa
la ayuda humanitaria está avanzando es
lento
pero progresa esa es un poco el mensaje
también que queremos dar